ladies and gentlemen welcome to another
episode of riffin with Griffin I say
this every week but this is another
special episode of riffin with Griffin
because I have another outstanding guest
an important person in my professional
life that helped me get to where I am
today on a podcast welcome to the
podcast my friend my colleague the very
funny the talented mr. Odgers Holmes
what herb
[Laughter]
I mean single-handedly probably
responsible for everything here we go
everybody you and Blake I had to arm
wrestle for who who's responsible for me
I'll take that fool I got the longer the
leverage over the top right before we
start every you know I think I found
I've been searching for a theme song
this one might be the one this is a
special hot off the presses theme song
and this one's by detective designs
detective designs where my man Rob
Kimmel and Eli wind ermine came with
some nasty funk theme song on
[Music]
this was
[Music]
[Applause]
wowsers
Oh check it out you like this I don't
know what to compare it to but it's
pretty strong candidate
[Music]
thank you that was I like how you came
in on that one I mean I had to pretend I
couldn't but the baseline drew me in oh
that was a fat one right I don't know
hey guys if you uh if you think you can
do better than that you better start
sending them in at Eric at Eric Griffin
comm you can go to my website Eric
Griffin comms you can submit your own
theme song but I don't know this might
be it I don't know if they can I'll be
honest I don't know if anybody could top
that one that was like goldfish in the
shoes it was like yeah that look on your
face like oh yeah tank anyway
um what's cool about the way you sing is
that I don't know if you're doing a bit
or if it's 100% real that's just my face
not the face the sound I know but I'm
just saying this is it's passable I
could go have a church I mean I might
come out with a EP with all my theme
songs you need to get a church for the
salvation well that would be for the
money too because I wouldn't be no taxes
okay what a church Griffin with Griffin
Church and kind of like that yeah um
what it's good to see you good to catch
up man look at us I know we did it after
what 13 years right
yeah but I've had now what you know you
know I've had well heck how long I've
had Blake on I know that I know their
story cuz you didn't know them in the
beginning right
I wouldn't know them I refused I still
don't even
yeah I I mean guys like the Beatles you
broke up yeah yeah my left hand was my
Yoko she broke it up yeah I didn't grow
up with those dudes those dudes have had
the fortune of growing up together and
speak in that language that they speak
yeah I always thought you would like the
adult of the group you know what I mean
well I was the only one with pubic hair
even more than Blake yeah oh yeah
oh yeah I was the old dog oh yeah here's
what's funny uh I was probably the
loosest cannon out of my friends who I
grew up with I mean what wait where did
you grow up outside Chicago Evanston oh
that's right that's why you got a
Chicago got out to your brother to shout
out to a home aka Iceman whoo I see more
than you by the way who do cuz he'll
come wherever you're right yeah yeah if
I suppose I might place Chicago he's
there and he's got like you know he's
actually calm down cuz he yeah he used
to bring like four or five chicks to
that I was like I don't know how he met
them yet he started to slow down now
that he's 42 but I was I was like the
wild aimless dude out of my friends and
then I meet these dudes Adam play Kyle
who are three years younger than me or
at least in school and for whatever
reason they were like well you wear
shirts with collars whoa so you must
know time and how to get places and maps
and all that and I'm like huh and
everyone else did told us and you became
like you had to become the responsible
guy out of nowhere
bizarre and then people be like well
what happened where were the other guys
I'm like I don't know I barely got here
like so you came from but you didn't
meet them until like yeah you were you
were in sugar when did you come to
Chicago like what's your story in
Chicago uh
just born there grew up there left there
went to college in Madison Wisconsin
okay right okay you and just College in
Wisconsin then did you go for writing I
went for swimming that's right you had a
swimming that's right he's pretend like
he doesn't know about my [ __ ]
athletic miss miss okay Greg Louganis
over here you right it's in a pool
billiards billiards pool swam in college
didn't go for any other reason like I
said total loser aimless no let's do
that's a great you got a way you got a
swimming scholarship but yes but when
you do when you just go to college to be
an athlete in an arena that there is no
professional
outcome there's no NFL there's Olympics
you never you never thought you'd be you
could be like an Olympic the Olympics
takes two people per event every four
years and I was don't think that does
European like they you can make money in
Europe no what is this like hockey [ __ ]
no nobody cares about swimming nobody
cares nobody cares Michael Phelps made
it hot for like eight years people were
like I know Phelps and lucky when the
one got it became an [ __ ] wasn't
named Lucky
oh that's okay there you go so you know
yeah I knew him but now you don't shout
out so I did that and I was kind of at
what point though when you were swimming
you know was it like did you swim did
you do it for four years three and a
half so three it was it like year two
were you were like what the [ __ ] and a
half what the [ __ ] am i doing like no I
got into a [ __ ] drunken bar fight oh
you were the original Lackey yeah oh gee
I was the [ __ ] shame this swimming
community and was terminated because it
was it was gnarly dude and I had all of
a sudden like twenty two hours of my
life back every week oh wow and I was
like oh you got cut from the team at
that way oh wow like let's just say I
went to lockup Wow I took a [ __ ] in
front of other men I was the only dude
who took a shower
underneath the television how hard is
that you ever take a shower in front of
like ten other dudes no I well in
grammar school and right PE my peers
like this and they're all watching a TV
that's above and you catch them dude
that's just like no we were you like the
hot piece in there because no yeah yeah
we just scared
maybe that must have been a scary
experience
what did you up for 24 hours 3 days
where guys it was a holiday weekend days
oh so you'd wait for the Courtney Monroe
oh my god did that change your life I
mean literally yes but like not I wasn't
like scared straight there wasn't some
dude who's like which would be
impossible I hope but it was just like I
mean I did have to front on somebody to
get a milk back he grabbed two milks and
when I got up to get the my meal without
the milk I was like and I was like I
think you got my milk now in your mind
were you like I hope he does hit
I don't know part of me was like you
just you're here yeah you'd see Oz you
can get in a fight here right like
what's the what's worse like they don't
care it's a side of you I didn't even
know don't make me take my shirt off you
I don't know the jail side of you was
like this when you're in there you're
like if I lose the fight I lost a fight
if I win the fight nobody [ __ ] with me
for the rest of the weekend right and if
you lose the fight everyone's like so
you hear I got beat up so you are you
acting like you won the milk fight so
people were like don't take tattoos milk
let's just say I got the milk I didn't
have to I asked him no but so then I had
all this free time and I was already in
the movies and like had a camcorder and
[ __ ] I was already like clowning around
you have a crew uh yeah but they were
just like fun dude so I was like hey
we're already drunk what if we did a
thing we're like you're pretending to be
this guy and I'm this guy and we like
film scenes or whoa
got you they basically like entertained
me you know I mean they're like all
right forget shirts Wednesday means
right two in the morning and you're
hammered but in high school I did like
the the student-written comedy show
which was kind of a ripoff of like sarin
live it was like sketches and got that
kind of thing so like going to college I
kind of left all that behind
and let's just in the pool cuz that's
all your time I saw you do all got you
got and then when that came back I was
like all right like I had now I got this
stuff bag maybe I'll start like watching
movies with more of a an artistic eye
yeah like let's say mrs. Waxman and
you're like a junior in college at this
point right yeah yeah oh can I I was too
stupid to get into like the school like
the communication art school alright so
then I just started taking classes up
until the point where they're like I'm
sorry you're too dumb to taste brain
writing that's the door but I took like
you know 101 like TV 101 film 101 where
you get to like shoot your short film
and then in TV they do like two
different multi cams and this is when I
knew like alright maybe you should keep
doing this
they took scripts from like the 25 or 30
kids in the room and they were the
teacher goes I'm gonna select the two my
two favorite ones we're gonna film those
I wrote mine and I also wrote my friend
who didn't want to write his they picked
both of those oh you must have been it
that was like your head was opposed to
be like but yes so like the only thing
that mattered to me was that my script
got a 49 out of 50 and the one that was
his got a 47 had if that had you really
yeah right right right that's cool
shooting would have been the first one
not a second but yeah I was you filmed
both of those sketches right no they
weren't his sketches they were like
scenes of like what a show okay I got
you guys got you um and so we did I was
like alright okay yeah this is that the
moment you were like oh I really I think
I want to do this for real
no but it was I knew I wanted to do it
it was the moment that I was like
somebody else is telling me I can well
like that yeah that validation yeah you
know I mean you're like okay like so
this is good
we're doing this we're making this
there's all these people like buying the
props for the thing I wrote people
holding cameras for the way like you
know other kids in their class acting
saying the lines I wrote
it was cool it was cool man shout out to
Wisconsin and then I could not take any
classes actually oh so then that's when
you made your choice [ __ ] it let's go to
LA no so that I was still in college for
another that was my junior year so what
did you graduate it if you'd weren't
history and you ask me anything that's
ever happened whatever like so you
graduate with your history degree 1492
you know how many times Louisiana
Purchase
just like Aristotle I don't know [ __ ] I
don't know [ __ ] it's it's not by the way
that's not like cool right I know I just
don't have a brain for that right yeah I
mean like I don't have like bandwidth or
capacity kind of thing where I watch now
is like a professional out here I see
other people that are like killing it
and I go yeah but I was like all right I
can't take the classes anymore but I'm
gonna like write movies on my own and
watch a ton of [ __ ] movies like DVDs
we're hitting right at this time so you
could just [ __ ] go ran a ton of DVDs
and I was just plowing through DVDs
watching movies kind of like doing a
history going a history class usually no
I did go to class everyday but that's
that was my school yeah I mean I was
like just watching movies and kind of
going okay like why do I like this right
why is this movie so dope what are they
saying like what what is this
what movie do you remember a movie in
particular that you were like that that
really resonated with you I mean you
know a lot of Coen Brothers movies
always let simple well so I mean but
like Blood Simple is not really a comedy
blood simple their first movie is more
of like a noir that's just [ __ ] cool
and stylized and like gripping but slow
you know I mean taught I guess is like
the word people always throw out there
for that kind of [ __ ] but then you have
Fargo which is like funny and like
terrifying and horrible and also like
fascinating like you can't look away you
can't and then also like there's like
some weird optimism to the
movie two are like taxi driver yeah I
mean like films I got movies they don't
make anymore so you became a connoisseur
yeah but then so and I'm like Wes
Anderson and Paul Thomas Anderson
mm-hm so like Bottlerocket Rushmore
Boogie Nights Magnolia that was like
those are like the Bible's you know and
I just love how those dudes could make
movies that were funny and also like
touching and like had characters that
you were like I've never seen this
before like this is cool
and I wrote some like dark comedies that
were like a hundred and sixty five pages
[Laughter]
nine you're like yeah so this is all
through college then you graduate came
out to LA with two scripts under my arm
mmm just ready and no one liked them did
your first wake-up call no it was I
didn't know who to get him to yeah you
know I mean through like a friend of a
friend of a family friend I got like a
lunch with this dude who had written a
couple movies and he was like look I
read 30 pages of your script here here
these are books you need to buy Oh
United mean and I was like the best
pages are like the backpack 90 how about
this I won't read any books and you
talked to me after you read the back 90
but so I was like all right all right
like I get it like this dude couldn't
even take the time to read my entire
script I need to like check myself yeah
so like read the books he was talking
about went to library or went to a
bookstore and got more books and just
kind of read and like picked and choose
and like highlighted and like kind of
like you start memorizing these things
that you really click and resonate with
you from these writing books you know I
mean and I was kind of like Reese
cooling myself so like what was dope
about senior year College like after
taking film classes was I was just there
were no rules write what you want to
write watch all these movies
sighs fantasize about are you not really
in the program no I thought you weren't
officially doing it so you just like you
were self teaching yourself Eric I was
an outlaw you would jailbird of society
but no I could do anything yeah and like
there there's freedom in that and you
discover things about yourself what you
let go in a scrap what you cut cuz you
know it doesn't feel right
then when you start reading books you go
oh like that was crazy
way more than that's got to go or that
thing I thought I needed to cut like
that was the thing that should have been
in there and so you did get the books of
course I did yeah a lot about you not a
lot of people would be like oh I still
need to learn stuff I mean like I this
is why you made it by the way I mean
this is like for people out there and
listening to this you you know hear what
he said he got some scripts he thought
it was the [ __ ] it wasn't a guy said
read some books and you said all right
I'm gonna get these [ __ ] books and
you did yeah you got it cuz you can't
front
fully yeah you have to like half front
yeah like 52% front look I know what I'm
doing here yeah but you don't know this
I don't know that I'm willing to learn
you know I mean like you gotta be
willing if you want the endzone you got
to do the work to get in there and you
get it and you gotta know the rules
right you can't just like wing it yeah
and get there you have to like listen to
people who've done it before and a crazy
thing about this business if we're like
steering into that is like it's not a
ladder it's not like well you get this
job and then you move up the chain and
they do a clock in on time you're gonna
move up the chase you know right or
there's no right way so you gotta just
like ask people questions all the time
and if they're nice enough to give you
any answer listen to the answer and if
you think it helps you like download
that but if at some point you feel like
you're not getting enough answers that
you like you're not listening yeah and
you're [ __ ] loser get out of myself
yeah but you like you just kind of want
it and you got to be like humble enough
to go like you don't know what you're
talking about yet until you read these
books read these books in the process of
reading these books you were like [ __ ] I
don't
[ __ ] or you were like I know some things
and damn I didn't realize this so like
what was the end result of like that
learning process I guess you know what
it is it's as a father of children now
it's like those toys we're like it's
like the board and then you get the
blocks or two different shapes like the
star of the circle whatever and then you
have to like put them into the shape
roles that they were doing so like my
script was just the blocks the shapes
blocks and then he was like here's the
thing that you put him in the hole so
people know what the [ __ ] it is so like
I just had to go oh I got the star the
star goes here circle goes here great
that's first X second that you know
catalyst save the cat yeah yeah you just
I just had to like organize my thoughts
you know to a point you don't want to
get to like clean with it or otherwise
it's too clinical but yeah right you
still put you almost ink on it right
here's a guy who needs love and then
Gwen comes into his life yeah right
right you don't want me to like cookie
cutter yeah but yeah I mean I just took
that advice and then I was working like
retail out here at Lacoste on Rodeo
Drive oh sure because of course I was
this is great so you were at Lacoste
Kyle was over at he was in a shoe store
I was at a shoe store before we met then
because these guys yeah yeah this was
before cuz he was telling me that he was
like a shift supervisor or something at
a some like like like like van van store
couldn't be a [ __ ] yeah I mean so those
dudes at that time we're probably down
in Orange Coast College yes and I was
out here just like in the real [ __ ]
world
folding Cola in my own bills that's
right
[ __ ] increasing khakis and so then like
I guess a couple like I was like man I
gotta I gotta get a real job like not in
the business because I you didn't come
here to forget fold clothes well I was
like I'll work retail and in six months
I'll sell my movies yeah bright you know
I mean like you have that I get it
you're like I'll mix it up I'll go to
parties on me people they'll like me and
then I'll say here's my one hundred
ninety page script is that what happened
give me the menus
didn't happen so ain't no parties at all
did you get to get to a party house to
broke I had to bob and weave and
diversify the portfolio and like started
looking for like industry jobs assistant
jobs people the dude who was like get
these books was like get a job at an
agency mm-hmm and I was like if I get a
job at an agency everyone in this town
know how stupid I am
I was like I can't do that he's like you
just get in the mailroom you work your
way up you learn about the ins and outs
in the business looking back now I'm
like yes that is exactly what you should
do because it'll like demystify
everything right you hear all the rumors
you see behind like the curtain yeah I
mean I'm sure they all just [ __ ] each
other you know all those assistants down
there in that little sweaty mailroom
it's probably half work and mostly
[ __ ] probably a lot of work but then
you also like meet people go-getters who
are gonna be like your colleagues or
whatever for the right career if you're
serious and if they're serious this is
like what you were going through is like
equivalent of being an open mic er or
comics you know like going you know
that's what working in the mailroom and
like getting a peer group right but no
yeah like yes it'd be like being an open
mic er but then during the day you work
at Live Nation ah yeah yeah yeah right
so you're like the difference would be
like I'm an open mic and someday I'm
gonna play Madison Square Garden and I'm
gonna be like this my favorite comic who
does this and like ghost of these places
but you don't know the business but if
you worked and Live Nation you'd be like
god dammit so-and-so that comedian
wouldn't show up for this or that or
like we couldn't book the venue so now
like we got to pull out and you go oh
wow like the reason that dude didn't do
Madison Square Garden last years because
like the [ __ ] ice melted during the
Rangers game or whatever yeah you know
like the business and you hear phone
calls and you hear like that your
[ __ ] favorite comedians actually
actually an [ __ ] or like your
favorite comedians actually like super
insecure like needy and you go
like I'm super insecure needy maybe I'll
make it or I'm an [ __ ]
maybe I'll make yes I did I'm a butthole
not NASA well only well the days you
director ders days you were a little bit
of an [ __ ] I always knew the days you
would leaders cuz I was there on time no
cuz it was just you'd be like okay
everybody but it was like what the
[ __ ] going on today well why is he
acting like that didn't I look at the
thing
oh he's directing you got to put on a
different hat you gotta speak in a
different tone guys you got around you
you're the worst best performances I
would pull you in the record with this
this isn't a joke this is real I need to
see Montez and so but yeah but I'm sorry
you had that experience so you're
working in the room so I didn't take
that job I was like there's no way I
could do it got you got you got I would
be found out and like just I just I knew
I couldn't hang with work secure so that
was your insecurities right there bro
why are you using the past tense I'm
sweating my armpits out so I was like oh
I'm gonna get a job fetching sandwiches
that's my speed I'm gonna go make imma
be a guy makes copies you know I mean
the the other side of the business
production where it's a little like you
could wear a [ __ ] t-shirt to work you
don't have to be like Jackie shorts with
flip-flops so I like started working for
jobs got an internship at a production
company off of a website that I don't
even know if it exists anymore called
entertainment careers net oh god it was
like I mean that era
yeah of like maybe before LinkedIn well
they were like you had to find it on
Netscape right yeah like oh so I had
that Lycos retriever grabbing jobs for
me got that job
on the Fox lot which was [ __ ] dope
I'm like look at me
I'm a 23 year old kid on a lot in
Hollywood automatically just like dope
Ness is like entering my body right
right yeah I mean what am i doing making
copies getting lunch being on there
being at the location in the mean yeah
just being around it you're in the mix
and so then this production company was
making got two pilots made and two
pilots went to series that year and one
of the creators of one of those shows
which was bones was always in the office
and he was like what do you want to do
I'm like I want to be a writer and he
was like oh cool man what's your story
oh my god I'm Schwimmer he's like so was
I this that's it come on over and
romance it's cut to cut to a montage if
you guys like building [ __ ] together we
have to go so this so this dude was like
I'll give you a job was like a PA and
I'm like this is my [ __ ] golden
ticket and it really truly was shout-out
to Hart Hanson he changed everything for
me because he was like what do you ride
him like movies I'm gonna be a movie
writer you know and he goes okay well
you know like you write a movie and then
it's just kind of out of your hands yeah
the director takes it he'll rewrite it
they'll get a bunch of people to rewrite
it whatever and you just sit back and
hope your name stays on it
and I was like ya know I know that he's
like you know TV is like if you write
something you're in charge like you're
the one who calls the shots like you
create everything and I was like okay so
then I kind of just like watched him do
his thing kept writing on my own was
probably not the best writers assistant
because I could barely type [ __ ] just
getting groceries and making copies for
the most part and I have my own office
and I would [ __ ] also if you thought
it was like you would just on the lot
you thought you were - [ __ ] yeah when
you had your own office - I mean and it
was like you know six by six yeah yeah
but it was your I had my office yeah I
could just hit file print and I could
print anything I want which is [ __ ]
crazy
because before that I'm like at Kinkos
printing scripts I'm like I'm like I can
either eat today or print a script
because this is like before people are
like letting you email [ __ ] you bribed
right right I mean it was still that era
of like you could get a courier yeah
people were like just email it and
everyone's like no that's not right we
don't do that
you know pre iPad and all that [ __ ]
so and like you know the fridge is
stocked grabbing like cherry cokes and
[ __ ] so you were basically stealing
from the office I was making sure that
inventory was being processed and
crushing pop-tarts but like yeah man
that that jaw and then so he like read
some of my scripts after a while and was
like do you need an agent and I was like
I mean that'd be cool right you know
because I'm half fronting right right
right uh and then so I got like hip
pocketed by my first agent back then oh
damn and he was like you're white and
okay I have mostly showrunner clients I
don't want to work hard for you peace
out so like I try you know you try and
make your own connections and stuff but
right after a year I was like I'm gonna
leave you and go look for something else
and for like two years I had no
representations but I had to go I was
like this is like a it's a downer but
you were still working for the guy I
worked for ED bones for two seasons
right okay then quit and so during that
is when I started doing second city Los
Angeles with Adam oh here it is right so
you met Adam Joe in second city right
right and then it was it was lust at
first sight ha ha
no but for real he guys were Bros from
the beginning he jokes about it because
you know I'm a weirdo right
and like when improvising like you just
go to you're weird and you pull out the
weirdness and Adam is hilarious and had
all these like dialed in characters yeah
already and I was like yes he's dynamic
that way okay and at this point I'm like
I'm a writer but my friends were like
you should [ __ ] try acting too cuz
like all you do is joke around with us
right you know these are the same guy a
couple of same guys from college that
where I used to film and whatever
alright right right so remember when you
used to do this get back and you like
and you meet people that way you can't
meet as a writer unless you're like
signing up for those weird Craigslist
groups or like you read each other's
scripts and then just eviscerate each
other yeah yeah nobody knows the [ __ ]
you're talking about you're like I
didn't like your script at all here's
why here's a 17-point yeah I'm glad we
shut this Starbucks down for this did
you like the improv though what you like
yeah yeah okay I mean I love clowning
around and like with improv you don't
have to memorize anything you just go
and like you let it rip my weird place
was I remember I did Groundlings one
year yeah long sigh and I I just I for
me it was just always sexual
you know yeah my go-to was like is it my
dick comes out you know whatever it was
so then I could tell it just was like
uncomfortable and I just was like what
am i do I am I doing that but it helped
with other parts of my improv was great
for making me a better stand up you know
making me a better stand up writer
because better performer but just just
that I would kill myself yeah I mean
it's uh each of them have their like ups
and downs you know and like when you
find stand up and like that clicks for
you yeah click go you know I mean and
like like I was saying I went to write
movies and then I realized like giving
it away that didn't click for me right
like I'm more of a control freak kind of
guy yeah so I'm like oh then TV great
so then like so you and Adam are doing
day one after class or whatever meet
Adam are like so let you live around
here he always jokes that like his one
of it they all lived he live with Kyle
Blake was still back in school and they
lived with this girl
like a roommate style situation she was
picking him up and she's like honking
he's like I'll be right there so like
let me get your number you know it was
that it was funny and I was like I'm a
writer you he's like I want to do
stand-up on my cool why don't we just
create a show Larry David
Seinfeld style so we like wrote a pilot
together I was gonna star him I was
gonna be like the showrunner dude and
like right off the bat there's so many
[ __ ] knuckleheads out here yeah that
if you just get that far
with somebody you know they're for real
you know I know exactly what you're
saying it's follow-through yeah I think
that's the thing there's be that
everyone's laughing it was like you had
these ideas with no follow-through right
I know so many funny people they just
can't get to where you're supposed to
meet I always say people don't fail they
quit right you know they just they stop
some people fail but no but you're right
you're still cuz even if you are and in
stand-up you know these people these are
the people who they don't quit so they
just MC forever right but then you know
who they become the go-to guys and they
and they've built relationships over the
years so that after 10 or 20 years
they're like yo uh I started this thing
now they have like 15 people that are
well-established
in this town that'll be like I'm in I'll
show up for that you know if they start
like I'm doing this stand-up for cancer
thing or whatever and then all of a
sudden becomes like a big deal and now
they are a producer of a big deal annual
fundraising comedy thing so you so you
guys write something you get that far we
wrote a thing called dorms it was about
a kid who goes to college even though he
wanted to be just be a stand-up so he's
like he's in school but he got one foot
out the door but he wants make his
parents happy and he's got like insane
roommates you know any man hates it and
he's getting like bad advice from them
and it was funny and it was very very
workaholics Oh like there were visible
set pieces this is the that was the the
kernel the the seed yeah because I like
I I mean like I was saying about like
the putting the pieces of the thing like
the structure I was like as soon as I
figured out like Oh structure I was like
okay cool like setting this up like
paying that off like dovetailing
whatever you know I really enjoyed
writing like big physical set pieces for
workaholics and for this there was like
some great [ __ ] and reading it like a
couple years ago I was like we should
just rip this [ __ ] pilot off you just
plug and play
[Music]
but yeah so and then when did you meet
so you guys exchanged numbers you
couldn't wait to get home and call each
other right don't wait three days do the
throwback ringtone we're like I paid
$9.99 for this ringtone of Method Man
and mary j blige but yes so then I met
Kyle in of his house in like a drunken
stupor yeah here now okay this the part
of the story I hear from the other side
is y'all didn't like each other at all
from jump no no it's this Kyle has the
darkest side of anybody in the world not
he's just got like he's got a dark side
right and he doesn't drink anymore and
he was drinking he was drinking this
night and this from the guy that went to
jail so I see what you guys got a long
as that was an experience that I writing
that was still in you just can't tame me
so this dude already had gotten in a
fight with Adam but that night okay a
fist fight Wow
which they got in every two years yes it
would just come to blows
and I was like upstairs and like it was
a two flat or whatever there's like a
how much how old are you at this point
25 okay so you're 25 and they're like 20
21 22 no maybe I'm I'm 24 and they're 20
that's a big difference by the one yeah
yeah it is it's weird how yeah when you
get around to 25 is yeah well you're
like all of a sudden you're like well I
can rent a car you know right you guys
can't got a collar just listen to it
yeah
and so like there was a part it was like
a party upstairs party downstairs and
like I was by myself upstairs like Adam
left and like nobody knew me and they
were like yeah and I was like what like
nobody here knows you and I got rolled
on hard I was like what what's up oh you
see what you would write to prison so
Kyle had your milk no so then I go
downstairs
and like they're like that guy needs to
get out of here and Kyle's like who this
[ __ ] he gets in my face after I
had gone and I can't even believe it and
so I'm like come out of here
I grabbed my Jamie Foxx DVD that I had
lent Adam I'm just like you can't be
stealing my DVDs man nobody knows you
and I'm like this is my DVDs he's like
that's Adams friend's DVD I'm like I'm
Adam Adam comes he's like what are you
doing [ __ ] ready to fight this dude
you just fought Kyle go sit down
right and then but you know and he'll
say this the next day we went and saw
Kung Fu Hustle yes what he did say
changed everything
really the workaholics you know the glue
the foundation that made workaholics is
what brought the crew together is that
and that movie is awesome yeah I love
them so did you all go together it was a
shoo-in Kyle I don't remember no no you
go to movie I'll see you at the Grove
are we fighting no we're going to a
matinee all right it would be stupid
like you Adam was like yo let's go see
this movie and Kyle was there it was
like what's up dude what's up all right
let's go see this movie and he's sober
and you got you guys totally bonded over
this right
you know and he's a director something
like that movies crazy you know it's got
it actually is a perfect storm of I mean
when I think about it now cuz I've heard
all of your guys's story and let now as
I hear from your all your perspectives
I'm like Dan this is real like he was
the director he had the equipment he'd
been doing it behind the scenes you were
of the foundation of a writer you and
then here's this great performer yeah
and you guys looked at each other like
with our powers combined you were like
hell I even talked about The X Factor oh
yeah that's how he was in the beginning
hair
when did Blake come into the picture
just moments later Oh what the fight no
fast forward - no I didn't meet him that
I met they were like hey this is after
the movie they were like we should start
making videos and we did and then they
were like alright we're gonna make like
a pilot to like take around town or
whatever
I think Adam had gotten a manager at
this time and we were gonna like give it
to him to like see what cracks off and
they were like our buddy Blake he's down
still in college but he's super funny he
should be in and I'm like I don't know
this [ __ ] and you also control
freaks you like oh my god I need to
co-sign this this I mean yeah and there
were two other girls that we had met at
Second City who were in the mix with us
too and they were part of the pilot
called mail order comedy I'll order
comedy which was like hey we're gonna
yeah we're gonna this is the age it was
right before YouTube but people were
watching videos unlike websites and our
whole thing was like we're going to take
requests from people to tell us like I'm
gonna see a sketch about XYZ and we'll
go okay cool Julian was around at just a
point no not yet okay not yet and so we
made a pilot based on our own ideas to
like kick things off and then be like
you two can submit like ideas which
today I'm like is a legal [ __ ] storm you
give us your ideas to steal Ben we make
them right I'm so can't do that anymore
but what's crazy is we made the we made
the pilot it was I think it was pretty
funny and like there was like stuff in
that that we still talk about and
I have used on workaholics but this
pilot wasn't necessarily off this place
comedy no this was a what like Bob and
day not Bob and Dave the what's that is
it mr. show oh wait I got you I was like
mr. show size sketch show type of thing
sketch is bleeding into sketches type
thing because the hardest thing of the
sketches to end a sketch right
that's why it's better to just blend it
into another one right and so what we
did it was like it was like all right
it's the weekly meeting a mail order
comedy you like what are we gonna do
this week I had a pitch that was this
and then like you went into it and then
like it either worked or didn't work and
you'd come back to the room and be like
uh that's a bad idea I got a thing where
it's this whatever and you know you're
kind of going yeah yeah yeah and so that
was that was a premise that you like
catch up with these guys and then they
decide they're not gonna do any of the
sketches from that week but you just
solve them but you so Blake's in now
Blake is now in and so you guys are and
kind of funny yeah yeah yeah had some
sauce yeah and then and that's just like
when you guys you guys are just at this
point this dynamic crew of people like
it really is amazing now when I even
hear about it like this now it's like an
amazing thing to hear about like where
it all came from I mean we just we we
weren't [ __ ] around yeah I mean like
we we all were like we're in this and we
were meeting we all had jobs and we were
meeting twice during the week and then
filming on the weekends yeah I mean like
we made it a whole thing to be like are
at Tuesday's pitch day oh nice and we
like pick the ideas Thursday you come
with your written [ __ ] and then we like
riff and punch up and then like Saturday
or Sunday we film it yeah okay guys
everybody out there I hope you listening
to how this works like you know because
people saw it's like such a silly comedy
and all that but this was like you guys
were professional from day one even
before you even got this is like you
guys had a rapport or you had like a
system and yeah and it just stayed in
place I mean we all just we'd all just
you want to we all knew that this
what we had to do you know I mean like
we weren't gonna be doing anything else
like we wanted this to be our jobs and
it was fun so like why not just do it
and like treat it professionally and
that's when the Wizards came in Ezard
wasn't that mad like we got this we had
this thing called crossbows and
mustaches that we sold to a company for
MySpace and so like MySpace was big
right then Facebook hadn't really popped
yet Facebook was out but nobody gave a
[ __ ] you know top eight was hitting oh
yeah in the top 16 you had about like
who you put in your top eight and then
like stuff and I was like man I just met
these guys but they're my business
partner in comedy and we're using this
platform to get out there but we did
this series called crossbows some
mustaches and that's when I quit my job
at slash fired from bones to take the
entire summer to like work on this thing
and like film it because we got paid
like $5,000 each why did I get a
blackberry so we did that and like you
know we just we kept making [ __ ] and
then I got another [ __ ] job like at
a headshot like printing plate place so
like if you had headshots you'd come in
and I'd be like you need like a black
border oh you were the headshot salesman
guy yeah you were up some best job you
were up selling fonts is [ __ ] you're
gonna want this the times new room
I like wingding I like how you were
trying to think of another font and that
was like the one hand I can't think what
a hell damn script yeah hell ateva or
what does that one Helvetica Helvetica
dumbass I combined a font with a
sweetener hell ateva makes my coffee
sweet
brought to you by hello Tifa
if it's it yeah and I had that going on
so while I was doing the head shot job
we also did this like National Lampoon
comedy troupe thing that was kind of
built around me and mail order comedy
guys but that didn't pan out because
National Lampoon that's just a [ __ ]
joke business and they were like they
all like went to jail and [ __ ]
oh that's right it was yeah I mean there
were good dudes at the head spearheading
it for us like this dude J Leggett who's
no longer with us which is a [ __ ]
soul crusher but we were like we were
told you know you're gonna get paid X
amount a week to perform and all this
[ __ ]
we were like cool and like I remember we
all got together when they were like
what should we ask for like what we
should be favored nations what are we
gonna be asked for and I was like I mean
I'm like I'm making 750 a week right now
I'm good with 800 are you out of your
mind
800 that's crazy I was like what I'm
there like 1500 minimum I was like [ __ ]
okay yeah you guys feel strong about
1500 let's go for 1500 and they were
like yeah 1500
the next day we all get there with like
the business people and [ __ ] and they're
like 600 yeah I go robbing you 650
everyone goes sounds fair okay alright I
what we were yeah I didn't even want but
you guys wanted last night yeah snacking
on pizza getting ready to be like rich
and now you guys like [ __ ] it that seems
fair that's cool and I was like okay and
then it ended up being something we it
was like okay well we're not gonna pay
you for like rehearsal time leading up
to the tour and I was like hmm so that
was the first day that was your first
taste of Hollywood [ __ ] and I was
like okay rehearsal that's kind of weird
but sure and then it was like alright
we're gonna do three shows here in town
- kind of like drum up buzz and give
people a proof of concept that we can
send to like colleges and stuff and I
was like
all right well cool like what we get pay
for those when we go on tour and I'm
like you actually made them I'm like
hundred dollars a week I'm out I'm like
I'm out guys we should all be out and
everyone's like no like let's be in I'm
like you guys are [ __ ] crazy and like
I I was there like you know get like
phone calls from them like don't quit
please do it like guys I'm trying to
advocate for all of us right we're all
talented we all bring something to the
table they're using us to make money we
should be making some of that money I
don't have health insurance the people
who work here you have health insurance
through this [ __ ] company I'm like
they have benefits
I know we're all scrapping by but like
we have nothing there's no like there's
nothing protecting us right now the
contracts we signed they're not living
up to what do you think is gonna happen
next so then we booked like a two-week
tour at like three colleges and I'm like
all right this is bout it and cool and
we got paid they're like whatever you
650 or whatever it was but it was
supposed to be like two months long and
I was telling my girl I'm like I'm gonna
be Road Dogg and be out there you know
spreading the magic same girl by the way
same girl yeah same girl [ __ ] our Kelly
um actually that was uh sure
not doing great either but anyway like
we did this tour and it was cool and we
got out there but like it was my first
taste of like people being like [ __ ] it
I'll do it and like if we're talking
lessons and [ __ ] to people listening
like you got a pick and choose like when
you're you know I'm not saying like
every time be like I want a million
dollars
like that's not I'm trying to do what
I'm trying to say is like don't get
hoodwinked and work for nothing for too
long right it doesn't smell right it's
probably not right you got to walk you
got to kind of go like I'm worth I'm
worth it cuz so and if you are somebody
else we'll find it but yeah I don't know
it's a tough thing that's tough so then
how soon after that was it when you guys
pitched for worker Hall so then we ended
up doing like a web serie we kept doing
videos you know yes still mail-order
Commerce still
doing it now I'm working at real time
with bill maher as an assistant getting
educated on the issues using my history
degree actually what it did kick in you
know the Middle East are you guys know I
don't even get into it because you know
how what has transpired and also well
dumb at that point you're gonna say stay
half fronting but yes so just I was
doing that and then at night working
with the dudes shooting videos and then
we did a web series that was like office
stuff pranks these dudes are [ __ ]
around it uh and nasty thing and that's
what comm essentials saw and was like
and that's not even the one you guys
really wanted to do well we wanted to do
wizards yeah but but that's cuz mostly
we were like tied in cuz we love wizards
and wizards is extra dope but we were
tied in with the people who own the
website we did videos for and it was
like huh that's a lot of like it's a lot
of opinions you know and they like they
got brought in and they're good dudes
but like when we started working all
except in yinz of like how we want the
show to be and like what we like what
they like how you write yeah television
show I just really like learned on the
fly how to make a show I mean I've seen
I had been in a room before yeah I've
been in a room before I'd written
scripts at this point I probably had
like this is back in the day when you
would spec a show yeah write a Curb Your
Enthusiasm or like a How I Met Your
Mother
they don't do it anymore because I mean
a show runners get sick of reading the
same show all the time right and then be
agents are like we can't sell a spec
it's a total waste of time if you write
a spec or if you write an original pilot
someone can read it as a sample get you
and then if that doesn't work you can
sell that show and then Kyle was also
ready to make he had the equipment I
mean you guys actually like turn the
missus on we didn't use that equipment
for the show we got we but I mean when
you guys did when you guys did a pilot
though like then you guys know your own
I mean maybe Kyle Kyle shifty ass the
window Pete oh we got new are we running
out of time okay we're good we're here
we're only at like 2007 but like we were
ready and so I was just like you listen
unless I'm trying to thought but like
yeah when you were making the pilot he
had to equip me he probably rented some
didn't ya weak rude up yeah yeah I'm
that we had to like learn and we got
paired up with you know an ad and like
I'm producer and all that from Comedy
Central may give us like 50 G's and
they're like they're like shoot a couple
minutes of what you think the show would
be and you guys and you guys [ __ ] up a
shot a show well we were like you guys
ruined it for a lot of people tell me
central said after that I'll look people
can make a show for this hey and here's
what I gotta say to people who are
scared to shoot an entire show get out
of my [ __ ] city get out I mean do you
want to shoot four minutes and make it
extra dope cool
now Comedy Central knows you could shoot
four minutes as a writer I was like it's
not gonna like we can do this we can
write something together with these
dudes in this website get everyone's
ideas harmonious tie it together and
show them that like we're not a sketch
group yeah here's twenty two minutes of
a show we make we make television shows
and the rest is [ __ ] history I mean as
far as planet Earth is concerned
well you've now listen you've you've
gone let's get to you now more I mean so
you like after work like actually
towards the tail end of or colics is
when you started the booty end yeah yeah
you did have a year where was like the
year of the booty you that booty episode
on workaholics yeah your booty eatin and
every the Chris Rock movie stuff I else
with your booty but you did you've done
some good stuff like what like what was
that like like you know going from
workaholics being on this silly show
then all of a sudden like you're they're
turning up you do you they're like hey
we want you to be a leading man right
huge mistake
that's how you know there's way too much
TV out there
they're like condors home could have a
show not look I look I I've had I've had
the opportunity to be in some super dope
[ __ ]
like looking back at my IMDB credits
every morning when I wake up just reads
it ya know I give it to my wife and I
have her just tell me she's like in 2003
just just working my dick I'm working
and I'm my wife because she's busy
reading it's our it's it's what keeps us
together
but yeah like top five do that movie is
so funny and like the fact that I'm in
it is crazy and then I got to work with
Seth Rogen and Evan a couple times I
have to interview yeah and then sausage
party and then just doin like cool stuff
like I did one episode of Modern Family
which is way better than doing like 60
like Adam that bastard
yeah but she also did the you were you
did the movie the way Adam was in I did
that he did the movie I was in of the
intern the intern yes you were the you
were the love interest in the intern
yeah and the bad guy yeah you were the
bad guy um which was crazy cuz you're
just kicking it with DeNiro
yeah how was that great you know like
you you wanna like just wring him out
for all his juices because acid tell me
more give me more yeah but you know he's
like 75 he's not
he says I'm done talking you know
everybody I don't care so you gotta like
pick and choose when to be like uh-uh
you can't be like Rob do you know Tom it
is 4:30 [ __ ] should I asked him
something you know but watching him work
and like the director like to do a lot
of takes and it was kind of like tough
and exhausting and you're like yes right
here this she's the nightmare I mean
that's our thing though everybody's has
our quirky thing but I here for her core
key thing is like people doing 75 takes
yeah she does a lot of takes and like to
her
my character kind of walk this tightrope
of he's got to be a good enough guy that
in the end spoiler when he cheats on
Anne's character and she stays with him
he's got to be a good enough guy on the
top of the movie that you go alright I
forgive her was staying with him because
he's a good guy he [ __ ] up they're
gonna make it work but you also can't be
like the best guy ever and then it's
like this guy [ __ ] cheated out of
nowhere yeah so like I had to do a ton
of different takes and then I also I
watched an arrow do a ton of takes and
at some point he was like I did I he's
like I feel like I I did that and she
was like no you didn't to De Niro he and
I watched him go okay okay you sure you
were saying to yourself Who am I to
[ __ ] yeah yeah if that guy's right
saying yes ma'am I've gotta be yes ma'am
the whole [ __ ] way yeah and like you
know people actors obviously the way you
get treated you could become a diva you
know like you're the one who can like
walk off set and everybody can't work
you mean you guys you learned how to be
a diva doing workaholic so it doesn't
you guys you guys you were feeling
yourselves towards the end of this it's
towards you get it arrived we had some
fun but like if he if Robert DeNiro is a
guy who's like she says do it again I'm
here to serve her movie or you know I
mean like she's telling a story I'm this
is like corny but like I'm the paint
she's brushing me I gotta go where she
says she's trying to do it you know and
I was like that's [ __ ] dope old school
and why he's probably the man one of the
greatest yeah you know so you did that
then you know that um champions of
course champions baby ten episodes of
fury and America was like no that was
dope and like Mindy project so like the
Mindy project was great I did a bunch of
Mindy project
why just hit it off with Mindy and like
yeah she loves you she trying to get
everybody loves you trying to keep you
working I hope it's great to meet that
charity yeah I'm gonna keep this
three white male India the Indian
woman's gonna keep the white guy
wordpress hilarious right what's up
what's up for you next what's going on
right now I'm writing a bunch of movies
three among three movie assignments you
also wrote a game over man game Oh
everybody know that game over man which
I was offered a ridiculous party in yeah
you know word were not all of the parts
ridiculous yeah but this one was
especially ridiculous okay I've talked
about it with everybody talking about
with you Kyle gives me a [ __ ] call
like you know won't you be in the movie
and I go I really I go sure he's like
well wait a minute let me let me let you
know about it first and he [ __ ] up
yeah he did [ __ ] up he's like well you
gonna get your ass eaten one of the
funniest some Kyle didn't do it the
premiere Kyle was busy fully focused
yeah he's busy huh he should have gotten
his ass eaten the premier audience lost
their [ __ ] at this point I was trying to
be a part a real hand could have grifted
you could have hit him with the Grif
yeah I'm sure I'm sure we're trying to
be a quote professional actor I'm on a
drama now you know Casey you know the
most professional thing about acting is
getting that [ __ ] paycheck brah yeah
I know oh yes left that check yeah
that's $300 a day way that woulda got
money at a trip to you know but I just
you know he put me in I did I did the
Adam Sandler movie yeah yeah yeah so
that was fun did you get to go overseas
know when I get was so mad I was like my
characters he was Jimmy I kept saying to
him like I think [ __ ] he'd in the booty
Jim sure to let the booty getting a
friend I would have gone to Italy if it
was like Jimmy gets his booty eaten in
Italy I'd be like okay well let's go do
this alright so you write movies but
what's up with the acting front yeah was
they put a bullet in champions and now
what champions was also but champions
was a cool and I'll get to what I've
been doing next well I did like I did
too episode or I did one episode of
Kimmy Schmidt the Netflix show let's
just uh just wrapped up their series I'm
a series killer
that was dope I used to go away get
hundred homes how about you boy but like
that was a cool experience went to New
York got on the show that's super funny
that still tells jokes you can do it
people you can write a show with jokes
and got to work with ellie kemper who's
just dope she's [ __ ] awesome and Tina
Fey wasn't on set Robert Carlock didn't
visit but there were I got to got to act
on their show which is just like the
like the perks dude I mean like hey you
wanna like making this business and edit
it but like the cool [ __ ] is that you
get to be on these peoples show who like
you you regard as like the best in the
business I thought one of the coolest
moments we all spent together was doing
that episode of Arrested Development I
thought that was like unreal that was
just the coolest like right and it was
such a like like it's such a like a
little Easter Egg just for workaholics
feel nice and it was like cuz he's such
a workaholics fan yeah you know and it
was just like yeah I just loved that
like you know it's how they revealed all
of you guys one at a time and then me
coming in is like that that was great it
was I mean and like when Mitch did
workaholics yeah that to me was like I
don't care what anyone else says the
dude created Arrested Development I want
to say reached out to us to say he was
like available if we ever had a part for
him oh I want to say that's how it went
down or like his maybe his manager
reached out to our casting director just
put the feelers out there and she was
like I do orga holics but at the time
workaholics was the coolest show in
Hollywood you mean during the entire
seven year run no but I'm talking like
you know what I mean in the beginning he
was like one of these things whereas
like you guys were setting a tone for
like this is look look what look what
happened right I mean we did want to do
a show that wasn't like I was saying we
and the thing I wrote with Adam there
were like physical set pieces and like
it was it was bigger than a TV show
seemed you know and we tried to do that
on our show that had like the loose
improvi feel but then also like super
dialed in stunts and [ __ ] and like
it's an office show they didn't even go
to the [ __ ] office today yeah yeah I
mean it's like I know you didn't like
that but it was like her oh they wrote
another episode where like the show was
the guys and like their friendship it
was great I mean I've always said you
guys you guys have phenomenal chemistry
it's like it's Three Stooges types of
chemistry and like I still say to this
day no matter what you guys whatever you
guys do it's gonna be like oh it's
workaholics on whatever yeah I made it
set your brand what's your favorite
episode of workaholics I don't know I
like I like all of them it's what I do
like all of them I think I like all of
there's not one that you go like oh this
is a dead or like one that's great yeah
I mean I see you so critical that you of
course you only remember the duds but
even the duds I'm like no I'm like I
like the one where be rad was introduced
yeah that was her favorite I mean that
was just fun I liked the one where [ __ ]
where they were like the it was a
funeral and there's like Swedish
exchange students assess it like I just
love pulling like dumb premises from the
90s and being like we could dust these
office we just exchange students yeah I
things like a funeral and like homegirl
died yeah I always said that that was
the favorite thing ever was like
wouldn't it win a when an extra is so
annoying that the people that write to
show decide we gonna kill this [ __ ] ha
she was a distraction I mean that was
that was one of the funniest episodes to
film I was just laughing during that one
I like that one what am I actually I
think about one of my favorite episodes
that she was like when we had to go to
court you know hmm
you know the yep hovercraft episode
right and we had day what was that
singing group that was in it was a
Jewpacabra right yeah yeah but who was
that what was that group that was that
at the at the set oh yeah a Black Keys
showed up that Keys yeah they were in
the epital okay yeah me know what I knew
something really was happening with
workaholics huh was when like I'm
walking towards the guy from Black Keys
to ask him to
take a picture right and he's walking
towards me to ask me to take a picture
right now yeah and I was like oh this is
like we are really in the lexicon yeah
people are really you know I didn't
realize how much like Montez until like
I was out someplace and you know you
know people like the writer types are
always writing right and I hear lady she
doesn't see me and she's talking about a
project she's I like you know we listen
we want a fully you know flushed out
peripheral character like Montez on
workaholics right this is what we need
an Argentine and I was just like yeah
but I enjoyed that episode - just being
in court just like we just had I really
had a great time film in that show I
mean it was it was just like how easy
was it it was real easy it was a movie
days what do you mean yeah because we
think I had to go from Culver City to
Van Nuys at five o'clock on a Monday I
don't know about your outer logistics I
wanted to beat up but yes on set once
you got always set we didn't give a [ __ ]
there was not really anything that was
ever serious or life pressing yeah there
was never any drama
except when jets I died um our IP yeah
but like I mean like I talked to I mean
I still see like writers all time you
lunch or whatever and I'm like how was
writing on our show compared to like
whatever and they're just like you do
anything we were just joke around like
go off on script and like you know
sometimes it'd be a little frustrating
like this that or whatever but they're
like but then we would just go over to
target and walk around by nerf guns
target was right there
yeah we worked next to a target everyone
and now they're on like other shows and
like there's some [ __ ] who's like
we're gonna stay till 2:00 a.m. you know
what I toured za Noir cause I felt like
we became like the dances dancers with
the dancing with stars you know because
it was like all these people were Tom
Green and II did you know these people
would come on the show you like
reinvigorate their I like to remind
people hey I'm funny we had such great
cameos towards the end of the run Tom
Arnold wasn't even that though it was
like we
like you how these are all the people
from our child yeah yeah Dolph Lundgren
built us like whatever's in my DNA the
fact that we got like Daniel Stern Dolph
Lundgren these are people that are woven
into me Blake Adam Kyle like now we are
playing with them yeah [ __ ] the [ __ ]
I'd rather have that any day of the week
than have like [ __ ] whoever's the hot
boy this minute is making your own show
with the guys do you miss like making
workaholics yeah because it was so easy
yeah cuz we'd be like that's funny oh
that's funny and then you do this and
then that right of course that yeah
that's funny Tuesday to Friday done and
then start again
yeah and like just you know the
characters yeah and like you know the
motivations and like you just if you're
in a scene and it's not even like that
fleshed out the dynamic of our
relationship and when we riff and improv
we'll find a thing in that to amp up the
hey man I can't give you guys a ride
home today because I'm going to meet a
girl you already know the guy be like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about and
I feel like sitting back that's cool you
have a girlfriend I mean you know what
it is and I'm gonna think that it's
extra cool what I'm gonna be like well
maybe you should get a [ __ ]
girlfriend someday Adam then he goes oh
really yeah get outside my tires are
slashed and Blake I told him not to do
it you know I mean like that's the lost
episode guys did you see the lost
episode of workaholics you just you
already know like who's gonna get
jealous who's gonna be supportive who's
gonna like cut the other person now yeah
you guys had a real good shorthand too
but like I say but if I ultimately my
favorite episode is the office campout
that'll always be my favorite because it
was in a pit of it epitomizes exactly
what that show was about these three
guys in their relationship right and
it's like it's the best if I had if
somebody said give me one episode so I
can know what this shows about that
would be the episode I would give
anybody right also our shirts were off
so I'm sure you appreciated that god I
know you loved our bodies we were we
were Schwimmer body that first year dude
we were like we're about to be on TV oh
you guys are really extra
running and right and then season two I
was like I don't yeah two three was like
fat armor I'm like dude well let's get
wood ranch grill again I need some of
those [ __ ] barbecue potato skins well
before we go like so what's what's
coming up but sighs you wrote the three
movies but what's coming out what can
people see you and then they dumped me
and Kimmy Schmidt just dropped I did an
episode of Damon Wayans Jr show I mean
they already they have you already put a
bullet in that one again yeah if you
want to catch the show it's like during
your episode it like goes today I did a
rerun a Seinfeld comes honors home is in
this program it will end but that was
live action that was fun and I played a
gym trainer which is exactly what
champions was America wants me like in
tight shirts and yeah I'm like you know
getting ready for pilot season Amer I
mean I wanted to write something and
then I just got busy with these movie
scripts are there any plans for you guys
to get back together and work together
again yeah we're gonna buy a Shake Shack
and just kind of get behind the counter
burger jokes like a chick-fil-a in
Reseda yeah now I got a workaholics
episode chick-fil-a it's like a mermaid
[Laughter]
but yeah we got to flick ideas that
we're gonna take out like maybe any
sequel to uh game over man I mean that's
always in the pocket but actually
doesn't even matter it doesn't we did it
we was in any movie you guys will be in
it they're gonna think like oh yeah
workaholics - yeah you know we got ideas
we have that we're going to do our less
like three hander like look it's the
three dudes for a couple reasons because
it's just we don't want it to get stale
I know and also like for Hollywood
they're like really the three main guys
or just me three why
uh I mean anything now yeah I mean you
know it's cool to shake it up so like
you always get the broad city girl I
really wish we would have I always
thought we should have done a crossover
episode we're like one of them dated one
of you guys and then like you know we
had this like what we're going on a work
retreat and the workaholics people went
to see you know to go to New York I
thought that would have been like a
great thing and you just do like a theme
song mashup - yeah no then they're done
- but they had a good run yeah the well
five I think five or six maybe even
seven actually because we've been off
the air three right three years now it
feels like a hundred years but yeah I'm
so anyway these these ideas are more
like ensemble cast that we are part of
it yeah what do you mean was just I'm
just lucky to be there no I'm saying
you're a part of the outside as opposed
to like right your brothers all right we
all janitors together midnight but ya
know it's working with those dudes is
always again easy you don't have to go
to some new set and like be like so
where'd you grow up and like impress
people and be and go out and like party
and vomit in front of them cuz you guys
have fought you've loved you know and
here you guys are I mean look it just
like I say it was a it was a real
pleasure to be a part of that process to
be you know and let me say this mm-hmm
we Blake saw you in the hallway and he
already I'm sure he said this on his
podcast yeah he was like we got our
montes I came early he was here he's
here a day early he was like he's our
guy
and then you audition we were like we
got him and you brought like like that
lady with on the phone was saying sure
you can like write a well-rounded
character but like you brought to the
table you and like when we got to like
riff
off the page you brought you yeah I mean
not like you you I don't you mean you
brought your mind yeah yeah yeah yeah
which was dope and like the fun of an
older guy that these younger guys kind
of got [ __ ] on but we were always dumber
than you so it didn't matter was always
just like a fun yeah that was always fun
man yeah I thought so too I just and I
were like the king of the [ __ ] in
the other - yeah I was like the I was
like - weirdo Wrangler you know I mean
it was like you know then we did that
other cubicle little web series you know
I mean and I was just like wow these
guys are people don't know how weird
those guys really are and let's not
forget about the episode in Bill's brain
oh yeah oh the bill and tez come on
sexcellent adventures that was yeah we
were we went out on a bang workaholics
went out on a bang with that one people
still liked that one
you know the people I was gonna be a mud
tez spin-off is like no cuz because it's
just you know we'd have to work with
those saying you know the show the show
we got it's not on the air anymore yeah
it's over this officially you're hearing
it here workaholics is not coming back
stop asking about it I mean in 10 years
when we're like we gotta do it's like
with Janet Jackson's TV pop down show
two nipples and now Adam Levine shirts
off nipples no let's talk about I love
how people are in uproar it's like look
hey nobody wanted his shirt off either
yeah like society wise well he's just so
different from the tattoos it was almost
like Photoshop nipples right it was
weird they just didn't go with
everything I yes so that little area it
did look like areola some yeah the
areola area and it was kind of a cup
titties you know I mean so you kind of
like well these are a little mm-hmm a
little feminine I don't know maybe just
I don't know
yeah in the weird area but but anyways
he's got the moves like jagger it's fine
that's fine yeah everything about that
Super Bowl was boring oh my god
did you who did you have Rams olá till I
died or movie so I feel the same way but
I wasn't going to go
again Sabella check and Brady I'm never
gonna do I mean it's like you're talking
about like the intelligent yeah yeah I
made the intelligent pick I went to
Vegas but I took the Pats and the over
so I still lost right right yeah sounds
a shitty game it was a shitty game
everything about the game was shitty
couple of the commercials were funny and
that's about it but it is what it is
but anyways you're also dad so
congratulations on that you just had
another kid write you a year ago that
year ago yes the family is growing your
family's growing my dick works I mean
that's great I can't of course you of
course you're the dad with two kids
you were always you were the dad with
two kids when you were with them yeah I
was the dad of three kids
you can come yeah that's a whole other
[ __ ] ballgame man yeah you start to
like circling back to career [ __ ] or
whatever like you got a reorganize
you're like totem pole of priorities wow
it's like oh cool there's an opportunity
in New York you're like I gotta be there
for eight months like do you move there
do you go and work there for a year to
see if it gets picked up for that second
season because your oldest is in school
now right yeah I mean isn't preschool
preschool yes you can't just be you know
taking him in and taking them in and out
of school people do it I know and then
agents just go this is what people do
and I go know these Hollywood kids
they're monsters they're monsters yeah I
mean they're fine yeah but that check is
by why you do it
I know even when your wife complains
you're like well I mean but like my wife
doesn't give a [ __ ] about that she's so
low-key it's like she's fun to be in a
two-bedroom in Van Nuys right yes you
just love she would just be like yo
don't do that dumbass show that seems
stupid
she's good that's a good that's a good
barometer right you go to her hey you
think I should do this she's like this
is stupid and then that's the end of it
yeah but sometimes you're like I need
you to tell me I'm great just once you
know come on
yeah it's in the eyes it's never like an
audible thing it's more of like a
unspoken yeah we'll look man I'm glad
you came on I really appreciate it
eventually actually want to get
everybody to come in at once I think
that'd be kind of fun yeah to have like
the three of you calm look we're all
Hollywood now baby
well Adam was the only one I have he's
the last one on the on the on the thing
and he's hard to get a hold of and I go
to the games with you gotta bring a
little device before it's all of a
sudden I'm like yeah so thanks for being
on the podcast but like talking about
your high school I'll get him on I'm
gonna pressure him with all your guys's
clips but listen man I really appreciate
you coming on and of course um you know
I wish you all the best and hopefully we
also we get to work together again hell
yeah that'd be great we can be like the
new lethal weapon
after this Lethal Weapon is done back to
back like the couple of early weapon
yeah do something we'll figure something
now but anyways guys that is another
episode of riffin with griffin the great
honors holmes was here i really
appreciate him coming on yeah the
swimming a jailbird don't take his milk
cuz he will he will throw down for his
milk but guys stay tuned and thanks for
uh you know continuing to listen and
making all your comments and hey I don't
know if anybody could top today's theme
song that [ __ ] was off the chain
but you could try but anyways thanks
again this has been written with Griffin
signing off and I will see you next week
[Music]